Should we be worried about the singularity?
Oh boy, this gets me into all kinds of interesting
So First question is,
we have to look at the likely future of artificial intelligence and all these kinds of things is.
. I think we can see lots of trends right now, we can ask questions.
Are we all going to be eaten by AI’s, these kinds of things?
I think the story of technology
has been a sort of a story of how do we automate things that humans do.
How do we take & ultimately, what does technology do?
What does technology should do is take what humans want to do & have it happen automatically.
That’s what we try to do with Wolfram language & with our technology stack
is have the humans tell us what they want to do. That’s what Wolfram Language is about.
Then we’ll go figure out how best to do that.
So in a sense as AI gets better, as our capabilities in these directions get better,
we will get better at the automating the execution of human goals.
One of the issues that’s sort of interesting is how do you describe your goals.
How do you describe what you want to do to a system?
We’ve got kind of 2 answers to that, one is in Wolfram Alpha
you use pure human natural language.
The other is in Wolfram Language where you’re using a precise specification language.
It’s sort of interesting to me to think about what kinds of things can you just describe in pure natural language?
What kinds of things do you need a more structured language to describe?
It’s kind of interesting in writing this little book about Wolfram Language I’ve been doing,
and I’ve been trying to write exercises and things for this book.
As I get later & later in the book so people sort of presumably know more and more about Wolfram Language.
I’m writing these exercises, I’m realizing there’s something incredibly goofy about what I’m doing.
I’m trying to describe in English something which is actually a fairly short program.
I’m writing these several sentence English things.
Then I see program this corresponds to is this really short thing that’s pretty easy to understand.
So there’s a case where natural language is not the most efficient way to interact.
OK so with respect to kind of AI’s I tend to think
So the first thing to understand is you know there’s, well
Let’s talk about what technology can do.
I mean, so technology
so I believe there is a certain scenario in which the machines in a sense take over, but in a rather strange way.
You know when we drive around with cars with GPS’s and so on
most of us like me for example, they just plug in an address
and GPS tells them where to go and then just drive wherever the GPS tells us to go.
Increasingly, systems will be able to predict what we should do
based on our sort of stated goal or whatever
systems will predict what we should do this, we should do that.
You’re talking to this person, you know this person has these interests which overlap with yours.
You should raise this point in the conversation etc., etc., etc.
All these kinds of things, and I think that the much likely scenario in the fairly near term,
is you know there’s enough auto suggestion from the machines that most humans,
most of the time are just doing what their machines are suggesting to them to do.
So that’s in some sense, that’s the kind of you know,
then you know the machines are in charge in some sense
although only by the choice of the people that they’re doing that.
But I think more generally, you know one of the questions is
imagine that you have sort of the infinitely smart machine and it’s sitting in a box on your desk.
Well I should explain another point, the
ok so there’s this question about what you know sort of scales of computation and scales of intelligence and so on.
Well I used to believe that there was sort of a,
that there were things that were just computation and then there were things that were intelligence.
I used to assume that there was kind of a bright line distinction
between the merely computational and the actually intelligent so to speak
Then I spent a bunch of years working on my big New Kind of Science effort
and I realized that was just not true.
That in fact there is, when we look at different computational systems
there’s a certain threshold that’s reached that we can start seeing
in things like phenomenon of universal computation and so on.
Above that threshold basically all systems are equivalent in the computations they can do.
So kind of the funny version of that is things like you know,
the weather has a mind of its own. What does that mean?
Well, it kind of, that actually has some sort of scientific meaning
because you know these fluid dynamics in the atmosphere and so on
is doing a computation just like things in our brains are doing a computation.
Question is can we say our brains are just dramatically much better
than the fluid in the atmosphere and the answer is no.
They’re both doing sort of an irreducible amount of computation.
Throughout, in lots of different places in nature and elsewhere
and in little programs that we can construct
we’re able to make things which sort of have as sophisticated computation as any other thing.
That has all kinds of consequences about making models and science and all sorts of other things.
But one consequence it has is that one no longer feels,
I don’t think one can feel sort of that the human intelligence thing is special
relative to what’s possible in computation elsewhere.
So this kind of philosophical realization was actually the thing
that caused me to actually launch into trying to do the Wolfram Alpha project,
about whatever it was, 12 years ago or something now.
Cause I’d always assumed I’d kind of thought about doing things like Wolfram Alpha for twenty years before that.
But I’d always assumed that to build Wolfram Alpha, to build a knowledge engine
that could deal with lots of computable knowledge in the world that one would have to have a human brain like thing.
One would have to do something that emulated a brain. I realized from working on ks
that basically it’s really, it’s all just computation.
There’s no sharp distinction between the intelligent and the merely computational.
So anyways, then the question is ok so you end up with the AI box on your desk
and it’s doing all the sophisticated computation inside.
The big problem for an AI box is well, you know it can do the computation.
The computation it does is equivalent to a brain, its equivalent to lots of systems in nature.
The question is, what does it choose to do?
The thing is that while, you know the one feature of what we end up doing that doesn’t
there’s no sort of theoretical sense of the,
the box must have these goals.
The box, there isn’t a, there’s no abstract way of defining goals for things.
Goals are things that arise for humans from sort of a long history,
of you know cultural history, individual history, and biology etc.etc.etc.
So I think that, it’ sort of nonsense to imagine that there’s this AI,
that’s it’s just doing its own thing.
It’s something where ultimately, lots of things do computation but for the thing to have goals,
goals are a very human kind of thing.
So anyway, there’s that sort of thing.
I think that the, oh gosh there’s so much to say about this.
I’ve thought a whole bunch about this.
Another thing that’s sort of interesting,
as we look at kind of the emergence of things that used to be pure human ability.
Like for example, things like image recognition.
That used to be something humans found easy, but oh computers find it really hard.
Well, now it turns out we’ve managed to get to the point that computers find it pretty easy as well.
One thing that’s interesting, is the reason computers find it easy now
is because with our CPU’s and GPU’s and so on we’ve reached a scale
where it’s somewhat comparable to scale of human visual processing,
to the scale of what we do in our own brains for visual processing.
So that’s kind of why we’re impressed now because our machines can identify ten thousand kinds of objects,
which is about the same as what we can identify.
So then the question comes when what happens when the machines get bigger?
Which they inevitably will, and they can identify a million kinds of objects.
Far beyond what we can do
How do we think about that?
What's going on, and one of the things to realize is that the machine
So the thing that we have to communicate,
when we have thoughts the way that we get to communicate them
is with natural language
I should say that I sort of view there of being some kind of hierarchy and I don't fully understand this
so I'm not going to be totally coherent on this
but there is sort of a hierarchy of communication mechanisms that exists in world so to speak,
so sort of the lowest level is you're an organism
and you're going to have progeny and there's sort of communication from you to your progeny
because you have shared genetics and certain information is communicated
by the fact that, by genetics basically
The next level of communication so to speak
is the kind of thing that happens in physiological recognition,
where in every generation there is a fresh brain and that brain is exposed to the world
and that brain learns object recognition for example
well then the next thing which was sort of the big innovation of a few hundred thousand years ago
of our species was this idea of natural language
the idea that you could go from one brain through natural language to communicate pure thoughts to another brain
and that's kind of the big innovation that led to human civilization
and all kinds of other good things
so the thing that I'm wondering and I don't understand it yet
is, so ok we have a different form of communication
so one disadvantage of natural language is I tell you something
and I've got a well formed thought in my brain,
but to communicate it to you I have to go through natural language
you have to absorb the thing., you have to turn it into a thought in your brain
it's all kind of inefficient
By the time we have a knowledge based language computer language
that can describe the same kinds of things that natural language can describe
that can talk about the real world and so on
that it doesn't have this feature, that it has to be reabsorbed by another brain
it's something where the language itself precisely defines what to do
you can just send it to any interpreter of the language and it can immediately execute it
so  you have a kind of closer form of communication
than is possible by any of these other levels in this sort of hierarchy
I don't understand what the consequences of these are but I think they may be rather significant
and this raises questions like, when a large fraction of people in the world know how to program,
what consequences does that have, what kinds of new forms of organization become possible
so things like that
But another thing that I realized is that we talk about human natural language
as a way that we communicate and we reason about the world and so on
One of the things that is a little troubling to me is
when we talk about sort of AI systems that recognize a million kinds of objects and so on
inside that system, it is making distinctions, it's deciding
so you look at the low levels in visual processing
for something like our image identify function
it is identifying things that correspond to you know, vertical stripes, horizontal stripes, blobs
other such things. Things that are actually very similar to the human primary visual cortex
and things for which we as humans have pretty good names
you know, it's vertical stuff, it's horizontal stuff, things like this
as you go to higher levels in the system it is making distincitons,
it's deciding, you know, it's playing some analog of twenty questions
or something effectively, It is deciding which mineral it is
it's making a distinction, this class of things are distinguished by the fact they have weird crinkled boundries
that have these characteristics and so on
something that we, where as these things have a different form
It's making distinctions but we don't have words for those distinctions
we have words for some of the lower level distinctions,
we don't have words for these intermediate distinctions
yet in some of these systems these words can be very useful
in making distinctions so to speak, so they're things for which we could have words,
but the actual evolution of our species and our language and so on hasn't given us words for those things
and so I have this sort of crazy pretentious name that I came up for this, post-linguistic emergent concepts or plecs
for these kinds of things that are emergent ideas that essentially AI's will have
that allow them to distinguish things about the world
so one scenario that I have to say I am slightly curious about,
is that there may be that there are lots of these distinctions that can be made
and when you start learning things in  much bigger systems, there will be these kinds of plecs,
the systems use to make distinctions between things and in  a sense there will be a big dialogue of plecs
among the AI's that us humans just simply can't understand
in other words our language advances a certain rate we add a certain number of words
that deal with certain kinds of distinctions that we didn't have before,
you know there are plenty of things we talk about now in technology that we weren't able to talk about before
but our language advances at a quite slow rate
and the question is, will we understand what happens in any if these systems?
Well the answer is ultimately, no we won't understand it
but that's actually nothing new, because when we look at nature
there are all sorts of things that happen in nature that we don't understand
we can have little pieces of what's going on
we can describe using simple physical laws and things like this
but a lot of what goes on, we can't understand
and even for theoretical reasons we expect that they'll be computational reducibility
that we'll have to actually simulate each step in order to find out what happens
So a few thoughts about
This is the kind of thing I like to think about
There are several other things, one thing I've been interested in
is how do we take human natural language
so in Wolfram Language we've tried to formalize talking about lots of kinds of things in the world
but we haven't fully formalized everyday discourse about things
It's actually important to formalize that kind of everyday discourse
because it's how people want to talk to their cars and thermostats and other kinds of other things like that
there's more kinds of discourse that we have to be able to deal with
so I've been interested in how do we take
so for example we have a predicate like x is greater than seven
and so we say there are other kinds of predicates
that exist in human language like, I like chocolate, or something
that is in sense a predicate, a different kind of predicate than x is greater than 7
but so I've been interested in kind of deconstructing the types of meaning that exist
in everyday human language, in everyday discourse and trying to find formalizations of them
the same kind of way that we found formalizations in Wolfram  Language for lots of other things
and actually, that subject is kind of interesting because
it has a long history but mostly in ancient history, particularly in the 1600's there was a lot of work done on so called philosophical languages
it's kind of fun to look back at the works of a chap called John Wilkins for example,
who had a whole book on the philosophical language which is kind of a formalization of everyday discourse
at the time, and it's actually sort of satisfying in a way because a lot has changed
since the 1600's and there are a lot of kinds of things that were particularly about the brutality if life
in the 1600's so to speak, we can just get rid of that whole section so to speak
um the semantic framework, and there's also a lot of stuff which was just completely unknown in the 1600's
mostly to do with technology and so on and also to some extent human orginizations
that can be added, which my final comment on this
there's more I could say about it
but final comment on this is
you know, one of the  things that's a concern is you look at automating lots of kinds of things
and you ask well what will the humans actually do when all the stuff is automated
the fact is in the next many kinds of activities that involve manual labor and things like this have been automated
in most parts of the world,  and a lot of white collar professional kinds of activities will get automated
in the next decade or two I suspect, and the question is, what do the humans do at that point?
And I would say the number one thing is the humans define the goals
because that's something that in some theoretical sense machines can't do
but some other sense, somewhat more cynically, well the humans just play video games
and maybe they play they're back to the middle ages so to speak now playing video games about the middle ages
and maybe in the future they're back to playing video games about the twentieth century or someting
But then I realized thinking about that and it's like, that's really terrible
but then think about what somebody from a thousand years ago would say about what we mostly do today
they would look the activities that we pursue today and would say the equivalent of those look like playing a bunch of video games
these are very meaningful activities to us know but from the point of view of a thousand years ago,
when there were a lot more practical issues about growing your food and all these kinds of things
the things we do know seem like kind of frivolous video game like activities
so I think we can expect to think the same kind of thing is going to happen again
although to the people of the times, so to speak, those activities will still seem perfectly meaningful
there's all kinds of other things to say about the future
Lot's of other things to say, but
Let me not spend the whole time talking about this one topic but thank you for that question